Aaron and Miguel here we had a chance to
hop in the commander's chair and play
some XCOM to war of the chosen DLC we
were able to get trigger time with the
stealthy Reaper and the brawny
skirmisher all while fighting zombies
and the chosen assassin likes and subs
are always appreciated and without
further ado let's talk about seven
changes you should care about and war of
the chosen number one Reapers are
creepers the new Reaper class is one of
three new playable characters and they
specialize in stealth on top of their
shadow ability which gives them the
chance to stay hidden even after
shooting they have a couple of insurgent
items such as the Claymore that can be
thrown and detonated later as well as
the ability to instantly detonate an
environmental object for twice the
damage and blast radius
this makes them excellent at setting up
ambushes in the stealth phase or working
the periphery of gunfights while
potentially staying hidden when using
the reaper be careful because they can
stealth into places other characters
might be revealed and we learned that
the hard way
throw on a sweet yellow ski mask for
added sex appeal number two
everybody hates everybody especially the
skirmisher the skirmishers a traitor to
everyone since he's former Advent turned
resistance he's especially despised by
the reapers and the chosen assassin and
the hate doesn't end there the chosen
hunter warlock an assassin all want to
kill each other like homicidal siblings
keeping his friends close and his
enemies closer
the skirmisher can use his grappling
hook to pull in bad guys just don't pull
in an explosive Advent purifier the hate
burns too bright with that one in other
words they explode number 3 love is in
the air to counter all that hate is the
bond system drawing influence from fire
emblems mechanics bonded soldiers get
stat bonuses by staying close together
and can give each other turns at lower
levels in our demo that ability rescued
us from the classic door jamb situation
when we were trying for the fifth time
to rescue the skirmisher from prison
these bonds run so deep that if a
significant other dies the surviving
squad mate will go berserk for a brief
period of time
number four photo finish the photo booth
is a bit cheesy but what photo booth
isn't the wealth of customization
options from backgrounds to poses can
result in stylized images that border on
brand-building
at least your dynamic duo's will be
ready for their personality driven
businesses after the war it's a nice
light-hearted touch in the middle of a
very serious campaign number five the
chosen are persistent and grow each
chosen enemy will set up somewhere in
the world and begin to harass players
and their harassment have practical
benefits every time they kidnap or
subdue one of your soldiers they extract
knowledge and information these make the
chosen stronger and more skilled the
next time you see them in other words
their reoccurring bosses who grow over
time each has a different fighting style
for example the assassin will
immediately try and incapacitate and
interrogate your soldiers while the
hunter will mark targets at range who
must get to cover or be instantly Kayode
we were told the assassin will actually
adapt her fighting style based on the
tactical decisions you make in previous
engagements
no one has ever done that paper no one
shall ever do that again
number six loot the chosen hunter
warlock and assassin have some pretty
sweet gear like a sniper rifle
sword and whatever warlocks have mined
bullets if you successfully kill one of
them you get to keep their epic weapon
and use it against their coworkers
hopefully that will play a role in your
decision-making process over which one
to go after first assuming you get that
option and number 7 okay they're called
the lost but they're really zombies the
lost are equal-opportunity brain eaters
and they'll go after XCOM soldiers or
Advent alike they are attracted by noise
especially large explosions in the lost
and abandoned mission we played there
weren't so much of a threat on their own
since killing one guarantees another
action but we could see them becoming a
real problem when added on top of
already harrowing fights with the Advent
how is the war of the chose an expansion
looking to you is this what you want for
your next Ironman run or are there other
features you've been hotly requesting
from the devs let us know in the
comments below and check out our
gameplay on the lost and abandoned
mission thanks for watching
[Music]